le 12 novembre 2022 vous étiez toujours
président de la Fédération française de
rugby c'est la première sélection de
Bastien chalurau et vous savez qu'il y a
eu beaucoup de bruit là avant et un peu
pendant la coupe du monde au sujet de sa
sélection d'abord venu d'acteurs du
rugby qui se sont émus du fait qu'il
était sélectionné Gard qu'il avait une
procédure judiciaire en cours pour des
faits de violence à caractère raciste
comment se fait-il que le 22 novembre
lorsque Monsieur chaluro est sélectionné
la Fédération française de rugby ne se
dit pas que forcément ce cas va prêter à
discussion ou à interrogation légitime
il y a comme je vous disais la
présumption
d'innocence on peut pas dire on va pas
sélectionner les garçons imaginez-vous
qu'il n ait rien à la sortie je crois
qu'encore une fois ou alors il ou alors
il faut supprimer la présumption
d'innocence dans l'hypothèse où il y a
du rugby féminin aujourd'hui parce que
c'est quand même souvent dans ce sens-
là mais ça peut être aussi avec des
jeunes enfants vous avez un entraîneur
qui est accusé de viol sur un de joueur
qu'est-ce que vous faites alors au nom
de la présempption de naissance
d'innocence vous le laissez en contact
avec des jeunes ou vous le suspendez
immédiatement je su pas immédiatement
non mais ça va loin quand même non mais
c'est VI ça veut dire qu'il il y a acte
c'est vérifié et CEA et cetera donc là
de suite c'est c'est c'est pas possible
oui enfin tant qu'on est pas condamné on
est présumé innocent vous considérez qu'
a présempption innocence dans un cas et
dans l'autre vous ne prenrez en fait
c'est juste une question de risque alors
quand B ch est sélectionné je suis comme
vous j'apprends que il il y a eu ça mais
je suis pas au courant du dossier j'ai
pas étudié le dossier et cetera je
savais même pas qu'il y avait un procès
moi sincèrement je sa je le savais pas
là vous me parlez d'un cas avéré viol et
cetera qui qui est sous nos yeux donc
c'est la sction est immédiate faut
écarter de suite cet éducateur c'est une
évidence j'entends la question question
de présomption d'innocence mais en fait
on l'a entendu en presque en fil
conducteur sur toute cette commission
d'enquête et ça a toujours été peut-être
un argument qui a été avancé aussi
parfois par certaines fédérations
lorsqu'elles n'ont pas pris euh la
pleine mesure finalement des actes qui
ont été commis et de leur gravité
finalement si un sportif tenait des
propos racistes homophobes discriminants
ou même sur aurait des comportements
inappropriés du point de vue V des
violences sexuelles et sexistes est-ce
que la suspension serait immédiate il
est clair que s'il y a des propos
racistes avérés comme VI sous nos yeux
c'est clair que la stion est immédiate
il y a pas on va pas attendre le procès
il y a pas il y a pas de il y a pas de
présumption d'innocence on est
entièrement d'accord là-dessus il y a
pas de souci pour moi quand je dis
tolérance zéro c'est tolérance zéro mais
dans ce cas de figure d'abord nous pas
au courant on l'apprend
et qu'est-ce qu'on sait on me dit il y a
eu ça il y a eu ça mais moi je savais
rien du tout vous savez demain c'est
trop facile hein demain je j'ai j'ai un
match je vais dire à une personne tiens
porte porte plainte raciste contre ce
joueur comme ça l'équipe adverse va le
suspendre il faut quand même un petit
peu de faut quand même des preuves quoi
je ve dire quand il y a un viol et que
c'est que c'est avéré les preuves elles
sont là quoi je veux dire une fille elle
porte pas plainte pour pour viol pour
pour rien donc il faut il faut se
prévenir quand même